cry a little bit behind the microphone
then we'll take that out and posts
everyone thinks I'm not abusive to you
who are abusive to you know we have
video evidence of you choking welcome
[Music]
welcome to the guardzilla Mendoza we
don't do vlogs very often but I got
bored and was like you know what let's
do a vlog we're currently social
distancing hanging out because of the
things going on that we can't verbally
mention it's of course thank God
bleep that though I was like you know
well could we do that would be fun like
for a video cuz like I don't know if we
can necessarily do a couch potatoes like
we typically do because there's a lot of
punching and choking each other and
though I was like let's do an unboxing
video cuz for my birthday my parents got
me like a hilarious amount of Ninja
Turtles action figure after you decided
to monetize that content I talked about
how it'd be cool to collect one set of
all the action figures able to get one
set of than myself and then it became
too poor to do the rest but my parents
over the course of the last couple of
months are like let's just whatever
spare money we can just grab a ninja
turtles fig like as cheap as they could
find it and they actually found a bunch
of them and they put them in this so
let's take a look at our haul Wow
practically in boxes itself oh no it's
the one that got recast with Seth Green
I don't know Seth Green is have you seen
Austin Powers no well anyway be cool to
have like one set of like the the four
turtles from every show not like any of
the dumbass gimmicky action figures like
here's them but dressed as Elvis the
target exclusive jungle very in costume
or the this ones especially the one
where you flip his torso II the one
where he he transforms and you flip his
torso so that he becomes a different
figure here we got um we got cyborg Robo
tech bebop and rocksteady so anyway uh
my parents are like yeah we could
probably find that and
naturally the 2012 figures are like the
easiest ones to find because they're
like old but not too old the eighties
figures are like insane collector's
items that are like $10,000 now the 2003
figures are all in this weird purgatory
where they're like not old enough to be
a collector's item but like not new
enough to just be there's so many of
them you could fill a landfill like a
Funko pop person so yeah we got a couple
of these I don't think it's a full set I
think it's so far what we were able to
find we got everyone from the 2012 show
Sun box them and we'll take turn I unbox
action figures to display them and maybe
actually play with them a little bit I'm
not one of those keep it in the box for
15 years so I can sell it for $5 at a
garage sale
those people are silly I will open me
the action figure from get this Raphael
look at him look at him dance on Leo's
grave [ __ ] you I got a guy from American
Pie who posted those weird tweets and
then got came to I'm finally the leader
and figures are actually a little bit
off model from how they look like in the
cartoon because these ones were based
more on the concept art that was early
in production of the cartoon than the
actual cartoon themselves apparently
when Nickelodeon but the rights the
Ninja Turtles in general they were
really eager to get the new toy line out
so they started on that first Robin
thing where the toy Department took the
early design and then that the movie was
suddenly stuck with like the shitty
prototype designs because those were but
the toys were gonna be [ __ ] you we're
gonna make something better yeah and
like these early designs aren't bad but
like I can kind of see why they they
changed like look at how angry he looks
at no point in the entire cartoon does
he ever look this pissed off then the
episode where he has a beard for some
reason cuz I guess Turtles can grow
beards in that Kurtz wit okay which
Ninja Turtle would be gay
[Music]
we got that's the shredder that's a
space alien oh okay
that one I'm concerned about okay that
one is so old and like so rare that it
says teenage Mutant hero turtles on the
front because it's from the UK where
they censored the word ninja and all of
the stuff but it's like a classic
original shredder and I'm super
conflicted about okay I'm not gonna open
that one it's gonna be yours if you want
to open them I haven't decided yet if I
want to know the whole point of this is
I want to build like a four-tiered
display I'm gonna open this red that's
not that was in the script okay [ __ ] you
this one okay okay um that's the one
voiced by Kevin Michael Richard that is
just think of any person with a deep
voice in a cartoon for the past 25 years
likes bones yes never opened an action
figure before David I'm trying to be as
neat about this as pocket compared to me
he's got a little boo-boo
I mean he's probably got some boobs too
but we don't get we didn't buy the
topless puns like Darth Vader shredder
you think this man is socially
distancing you think this man is wearing
a mask it's right in front of ours
so confused I don't know what to believe
anymore okay you know what this reminds
me of like I've never done an unboxing
video before except for like the play
button I don't want the comments to be
mad at us for opening [ __ ] too violently
what are those is that a is that a big
catalogue of other other fine products
you should buy I want to buy the one of
these dumbass turtle bikes here so yes
okay so there's even more [ __ ] you can
buy here I don't give a [ __ ] all right
oh is there the little twisty wires yeah
and I was though I was just like pulling
him out of there earlier to like look
like look at like he was struggling
against his restraint like he's been
tied down okay I'm starting those a
theme I think we need to talk about okay
he's got one arm free he can use his
little shredder arm legit right iliza
he's gonna he's gonna shred lies his
other restraint I'll get my revenge and
then they'll undo it with time-travel so
I'll have to get my revenge a second
time slightly later
having done it twice will greatly reduce
the effect well no he's Cape so we got
also it goes into his back it like
inserts into his back yeah like like
there's a hole in his body in the back
his cape attaches comes back way to give
you a quick rundown Ninja Turtles is
basically a parody of it like eighties
comics that were overly dark
okay so let's like duels assembly on the
table of our action figures Raffaele
that one that's voiced by dark laser you
know let's show some love to some of
these figures so I actually of all of
these this was the only one of the only
ones I already had as a kid dread allure
he's the one who's a space alien shred
Eliezer is just some Asian guy named
Oroku Saki in the reboot cartoon that's
this one
Oroku Saki is a fake persona and he's
actually an alien disguised as a human
and Saki again and in the in the the new
cartoon where he's burn victim man yeah
this was the only one that actually
already had as a kid this is gonna be
such a bad video I know ok I would like
to apologize to everyone the years for
what I must do
that wasn't so bad
here's the shred Eliezer and he's got
the best evil laugh in this cartoon
hands they're so tight it's so hard to
put the thingamajigger you go and he's
got this and he's got it he's got some
swords here
everyone's got accessories but I'm like
I'm only interested in the ones that
like they actually hold in the cartoon
do you know they cut his head off with
one of these in the show
[Music]
what do you like better
uh this one he's got the cooler voice
and also he's a alien and this one's
just a this one's just a petty [ __ ]
it's like come on dude don't be greedy
you've already got enough revenge take a
break from the revenge for like just
five minutes nobody likes reheated and
revenge
so this Ninja Turtle here is voiced by
Sean Astin who you'll know as the other
guy from Lord of the Ring and then he'll
just stand up like this there you go
Rafaela cameras that way don't put your
back to the audience you jackass
okay I'm gonna who's this guy that's
Mikkel Angelo he's the goofy party dude
this guy's about to assassinate his
predecessor
very neat actually see oh wow that that
[ __ ] that blister card thing or
whatever it's called it's in perfect
condition so we have his nunchucks his
nunchaku
[Music]
[Applause]
there's some grippy so I wonder what
he's what I wonder what he's gripping
here you know why is he good well I
wonder what he's gripping here you know
what that's totally on brand for
Michelangelo look you he's cool
looks Pisa in the one foot probably
doesn't run if I were to guess what was
all that powder in the back of your car
you said it was flour but now I'm
starting to get really concerned I
borrow your vacuum which one should I
open nasha
open the old Michelangelo from the other
show actually wait this is Raphael
Raphael is a [ __ ] you don't haven't the
Michelangelo from the mm do Raphael okay
we'll open old wrath
[Music]
and then there's a ninja squirtle inside
you know squirtle is that like a like I
look like a little toy that you can like
use to squirt on your friends okay gotta
undo the wires back here I hate these
things
I actually I made a monster out of
lightning with these like I took all
these bendy wires and then I like tied
them together until I made a monster out
of him and he was like you looked like
he's made of electricity anyway look
it's a raft my L okay look so here's
here's the there's very different design
philosophies across these two different
figures but you know they're still very
recognizable as it's kind of cool seeing
like you know what changed between the
two generations if what's weird is that
like in both shows they never look this
aggressive something I love about Ninja
Turtles is that things always make them
look [ __ ] pissed there's a bunch of
accessories here for the Raphael the one
that looks like string yeah I guess he
has like a some kind of zipline
accessory in here you set this up on one
thing and then he set this up to this
other end up somewhere else and then you
use the handle and he zip lines down and
I bet there's footage of a kick-ass
action figure of him ziplining that's
what they put in the commercials we got
two Leonardo's here no I don't know the
bulb Donatello what's wrong with you
there dog tell us the purple one well
anyway to Donatello's which one you want
to open it says ages 4 and up so it's it
I can't do this yet I'm not old enough
[ __ ] dude do all themself [ __ ] I got to
tell my parents to take these back yeah
yeah you might choke on one of these I'm
gonna try to open this a little bit
unconventional
[Music]
Oh God please stop doing it like that
I'm so hard to watch please please go
back to the thing you were doing before
okay hold on I would like to just take a
moment to comment on the fact that he
has like a axe and a what's the other
thing why does he have those attachments
to go at the end of his his boast that
at no point does he ever ever in the
show have something like that it's just
a poster he never has an axe at the end
of it
[Music]
okay god damn it
okay so he's gonna he has his gripping
that long staff that long rod
[Music]
it's the the one that kisses the teenage
girl a whole bunch of times guess what
April and I have been up to I like how
these are like kind of gettin old enough
and like wherever they were stored like
they weren't kept ventilated enough so
like the plastic has like this ugly
yellow eachine over it and you look you
got even more throwing star oh oh this
is the first one that I think has had a
big twisty tie around it look he's got a
big twisty tie around his bubble this
figure also gave him one of these I know
first and why did they keep giving him
bladed weapons did they think the action
figure would be too boring with just the
staff like both of them have one of
these like sure his is he's way more
well endowed with his what is this
called this thing what is that what is
that
do you remember what that's called look
they're both purple and they got a
little staff aliy thing his staff is way
less interesting he's not as
well-endowed as staff wise as this one
but between the two of them this one has
the voice that isn't as annoying again
we still have all these collectible I'm
gonna swallow all of these choking
hazards I guess these are kind of
something that the eighties figures had
more of cuz I know this shredder has a
whole bunch of stuff kind of like that
you can see right here
so I think they were trying to like do
like a send-up of like the 80s toys but
I haven't want this like plastic frame
thingy open an action figure you [ __ ]
stop dusting my heads you're gonna open
the the Leonardo low okay
so Leonardo we got sward we got three
little knives we got two throwing stars
and we got a little like a dagger sure
what he's got some a stabby thing look
it's got a little name tag on he's got a
little name tag on it says Leo right
here
we gots award sword and sword oh he has
two of those and one of them is slightly
longer than the other Seth Green okay
I'm gonna give him the smaller one the
larger one stays sheath why cuz you have
the scabbards you need to have a sheath
in the scabbard well so I put it in his
left hand because Michelangelo or
Leonardo who or whoever the hell this
bastard is he's left-handed
he's a nubile young leader look it's
Jason Biggs about me Seth Green okay so
the question I want to pose to you
audience is should I find like another
one of this figure that's like loose and
out of the box for my display purposes
or should I open that one because that
one's the oldest figure here and it's
like the box and the figure itself are
both in such hilariously beautiful
condition that they look like they
basically just came right off the shelf
that makes me concerned and I feel weird
opening something that's like that
pristine from that long ago so what do I
do
okay so this is this is my collection as
it stands with the 80s figures as well I
collected those by myself and also that
fidget spinner and so it's kind of cool
seeing like three generations of turtles
figures
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who's gonna pick this [ __ ] up huh
you me yes fall killer okay yeah that's
right all right to live here
[Music]
[Music]